you
this is Wu Kong the enduring the Swift
with the heart of a trickster he is an
unrestrained primal warrior wukong's
abilities reflect his stealthy and
extremely deadly nature iron job cooks
an enemy with his staff causing its
target to keel over while also knocking
down enemies within a radius if Wukong
falls in battle while active depay
restores a percentage of his health and
provides some temporary invulnerability
each subsequent death reduces the
restored health while also trimming down
his energy total cloud Walker engulfs
Wukong in a cloud of smoke stunning
nearby enemies and allow him to move
freely on the battlefield draining
energy based on distance traveled speak
softly and care
stick ten Oh primal fury equips Wukong
slow South imposing incredibly deadly
melee attacks with each subsequent hit
staff groves causing greater damage
adding mods to blue Kong's loadout will
royally increases deadliness range mods
will positively affect iron job cloud
Walker and primal fury while duration
will benefit defy and cloud Walker
adding strength and melee monster - mix
will help iron jab and final fury become
even more deadly everybody's got
something to hide Teno acceptable calm